وصلنا لموضوع مثير للاهتمام ومثير للجدل
ايضا ابراهيم انت شو رايك في جدل الخيانه
رح اجي هلا لموضوع هل ممكن يكون الاعتراف
كافي للمسامحه انت قلت لي قبل شوي بانه لا
انت بتنصح بعدم الاعتراف انا شخصيا اعتقد
انه زي ما حكيت لك الرجل والمراه
ممكن يغفروا لكن ما بنسوا وهذي موضوع عدم
النسيان موضوع صعب لانه دائما بضل يلف راس
الشخص وحقيقه يعني العلاقه بعد الخيانه هي
علاقه قايله للسقوط اكيد طبعا بس على كل
حال يعني الخيانه هي مرفوضه بالتاكيد
بعتقد بانه المساله مساله المسامحه هي
مساله نوعا ما نسبيه لانه بتتعلق بالحب
والعشره والقدره ايضا على النسيان ولكن
نيمار اللي هو اللاعب البرازيلي الشهيد
المشاهدين كان شجاع وربما في ممكن نقول
انه كان متهور ولكن ليش لانه ببساطه اعترف
قبل ايام بخيانته لصديقته برونه النجم
المنتخب البرازيلي اعلن في منشور يعني في
منشور على الانستقرام مش بس اعترف لها
بشكل خاص خيانته لصديقته واكد انه لا تخيل
لا يتخيل حياته بدونها لاعب باريس سان
جيرمان اكد بانه كان مخطئ واعتذر لحبيبته
ولعائلتها على الالم الذي سببه لهم بسبب
خيانته الطائشه
نيمار مشاهدينا فتحتها سيده برازيليه تدعى
فرناندا كامبوس وهاي السيده الجريئه اكدت
ايضا انه ني موري كان على علاقه فيها وهو
الامر الذي اكده اللاعب اخيرا ايضا
[موسيقى]
وفقا لخبره العلاقات في مدينه نيويورك
سوزان وينتر اذا معنى لميس لتعلق على هذا
الموضوع تفضلي المزيد من التفاصيل
وفقا لخبيره
العنته حالات للبوح بحقيقه الخيانه والكشف
عنها الكاتبه الامريكيه تؤكد ان اخبار
الشريك بالخيانه يرجع دائما لنوع الخيانه
التي كانت وهل هي لمره واحده ام مرت
متعدده كذلك تؤكد الكاتبه ان الاعتراف
بالخيانه يجب ان يكون بطريقه صحيحه وعن
طريق الدخول بعلاج النفسي ومشوره نفسيه من
اجل اللغه المستخدمه في الاعتراف الاعتراف
بالخيانه يجب ان يكون مباشرا حين يشك
الشريك بذلك حيث ان الانكار لا فائده منه
في هذه الحاله ايضا فان التحلي بالصدق في
موضوع الخيانه ربما يخفف الالم الذي قد
يشعر به الشريك اذا ما اكتشف الامر بنفسه
على كل حال سالنا الناس في مصر برايكم هل
الاعتراف بالخيانه خيار
[موسيقى]
في ناس بتختار بس انا كشخص بحس ان هو
الزام عليا ان انا لما اكون حد وهو عزيز
عليا قوي وفي امانه بيني وبينه ان دي كده
انا بعمل حاجه في حقه ومش صح الصراحه
اصارحه عشان انا بعد كده يعني ابقى انا
عملت اللي عليا هو لو تقبل فانا هحاول
اشتغل على نفسي وان انا برضو ان انا اكون
جديري به لان هو قدرني وداني محاره ثانيه
ومش مره واحده بس
انا اشتغل على نفسي لان هو اداني فرصه
فالواحد لما يبقى قادر كده ويقدر يخون
طبعا لازم يعترف هنا بقى ده بيرجع لضميرك
انت بقى هنا ضميرك قنبك بقى وخلاص فانت
لازم بقى تعترف بالخيانه اه اعترف له
واقول له واتاسف له مثلا اقول وجهه نظري
كانت ايه او كده وخلاص واحد دافح حد ذاته
مشكله ولو خبيت عليه المشكله هتبقى اكتر
الصح ان انت لازم تقول له
[موسيقى]
نرحب مشاهدينا في الاستوديو بهدى مؤكد
مدربه الحياه للحديث اكثر طبعا عن موضوع
الخيانه اهلا بك يا ست هدى معنا تفضلي
صباح صباح الخير طيب يعني موضوع جدلي
واراء كثيره في من يقول لا لازم الاعتراف
والصدق يعني احنا لا نداوي الخطا بالخطا
ولكن في ناس تانيين مثلا ابراهيم من رايه
بانه لا يفضل ان لا نعترف ابدا نصلح من
شاننا ولكن لا نعترف العلم شو بقول ما هو
على حسب الخيانه يعني في خيانه المفروض
انه الواحد يعترف فيها وعلى حسب شو هي
الخيانه اللي لازم نعترف فيها والخيانه
التي لا نعترف فيها يعني انه لا نعترف
فيها مثلا خيانه التفكير يعني وانا رايحه
صار في حسيت انه في شيء بيني وبين شي شخص
يعني صار في طاقه بيني وبين هذا الشخص هلا
هاي خيانه عن جد لا هاي ما بتعتبر خيانه
بس اما اروح البيت واحفز نفسي على التفكير
بهذا الشخص انه خلص التقينا وصارت خلينا
نعرف شو انواع الخيانه اوكي مثل ما حكينا
في خيانه بالتفكير في خيانه لقاء في
خيانات الناس بتعتبر انه هي خيانه وهي
بالاصل مش خيانه يعني انه بس انه حكينا
يعني في زوجات مثلا انه بتفكر انه خلص
لانه حكى مع صديقته او طلع معها هاي مش
خيانه او نظر لامراه او مجرد نظر لامراه
اخرى فعلى اسباب الخيانه يعني الواحد انه
يعترف او ما يعترف على حسب شخصيه الشخص
يعني ممكن انا ما اعترف بس يعني عذاب
الضمير راح يانبني اكثر من انه لو اعترفت
على حسب شخصيه الشريك اذا هو راح يتقبل
ولا لا في فرق بين المراه والرجل يعني انه
مثلا هل الرجل يتقبل الخيانه المراه تتقبل
من يتقبل الاعتراف يعني بشكل اكبر
هو المفروض انه نفس الشيء بس هو غالبا
مجتمعاتنا العربيه انه بتلاقي انه الرجل
ممكن انه يعترف لانه ممكن تعتبر انها نزوه
خطا
انه يمكن التقصير من المراه بس للمراه صعب
جدا انه مش بس الزوج اللي ما راح يتقبلها
كمان الاهل كمان ممكن تعتبر ان هي ام غير
جيده مع انه هي ما خامس اطفالها يعني ما
ما حسبت فصعبها للمراه بس احنا ما بدنا
نقول يعني بناء على هذا الكلام انه المراه
لا يجب ان تعترف اذا خانت والرجل مش مشكله
بس على المقاطعه يعني فكره انه المراه
تعترف للرجل بانها خانت فكره كارثيه لانه
الرجل انا يعني شخصيا لا اعتقد انه ممكن
يسامح وممكن تحدث ضرر كبير في العلاقه
تماما يعني راح تنحط على المراه اصعب من
الاحكام اللي راح تنحط على الرجل هي هاي
النقطه ابراهيم اللي انا كنت بدي اوصلها
انه بغض النظر نعترف او لا نعترف او يجب
ان نعترف ام لا مش مهم اعترفنا شو بصير
بعدين ممكن انه الواحد يكون عماله بخاطر
بانهيار العلاقه بشكل تام سواء كان من خان
هي الرجل او المراه او او ممكن بالعكس هذه
صفحه جديده على حسب الشخص اللي انخان يعني
ممكن انه هذا الشخص اللي نخان ممكن انه
خلص يسامح بس في شروط مثلا انه احس انه
هذا الاعتذار اعتذار حقيقي ان هو فعلا
حابب انه يصلح هاي الشغله انه يخليها تحس
بالامان
طيب يعني في انا عندي سؤال يعني في بالي
ومتردد اساله لكن يعني في ناس بتقول انه
عندما تخون المراه تخون بقلبها وعقلها
وجسدها بينما الرجل احيانا لا يخون في
قلبه وعقله في فرق يعني
لانه المراه عاطف
[موسيقى]
على الرجل ان يكون اكثر حصا على عادتي
وعدم البوح باسرار خاصه شجاع اعتبر
الاعتراض بالخطيه الكبرى انت الخطيئه مو
لمن ترتكبها وانما لما لما تحاول تخفيها
هاي الخطيئه الكبرى انه ثاق من عنده او هي
طاقه من عندك تقدر تصارحه بهالموضوع وتقول
انه عندي صداقه وكذا فتاه
والله الحمد لله انا ما يعني ما عندي
هالشيء يعني ما عندي هالموقف فوق وممكن
اذا اريد اعترف ممكن يعني ضمنيا يعني حسب
الخيانه مو اكو مواضيع ما تتوجب تنحكي لا
ما اقول له شلون اقول انا ما يصير
على شغلات مو زينه يعني واحد يبقى السر ما
ينبع اي واحد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات